le poulet c'est la protéine animale la
plus consommée au canada c'est aussi la
plus économique mais dans la dernière
année son prix a bondi de 10% ces
augmentations et la rareté de certaines
coupes inquiète de plus en plus les
consommateurs
l'épicerie a tenté de comprendre les
facteurs qui expliquent que le poulet se
vend maintenant à plus de 8 dollars le
kilo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
premier facteur la main d'oeuvre
cet été une grève a perturbé l'une des
plus grosses usines de poulet au pays
celle d'exceldor à saint-anselme malgré
la fin du conflit
tout n'est pas réglé
notre jeu c'est un enjeu de pénurie de
main d'oeuvre nos usines fonctionnent
nous ici à 65 à 75 % du reiki main
d'oeuvre c'est dans les autres usines au
canada chez d'autres qu'on fait ça c'est
la même chose qu'on voit surtout dans
l'avenir du canada dans le marché canada
central cette pénurie de main d'oeuvre
va faire qu'on sera pas en mesure de
transformer des oiseaux dans les décors
que les détaillants recherche des
aspirateurs recherchent le segment
consommateurs à lui seul exceldor et
olymel abate transforme 96% des poulets
du marché québécois exceldor nous a
ouvert ses portes afin de constater
l'ampleur de ce travail à leur usine de
saint bruno à titre d'exemple d elyo
depuis l'année dernière
pénurie des louanges rareté d'elle sur
le marché on voit beaucoup de pression
et de filets de poulet la partie
intérieure de la poitrine de poulet
et c'est possible que dans les semaines
et mois à venir ne soit pas en mesure de
tout découper les oiseaux donc assez
d'oiseaux mais il pourrait avoir
certaines j'irai pas pénurie même rareté
de certaines déco ceux de marché
même si on mécanise les usines se
trouvent beaucoup de personnel pour
rattraper à battre harry valoriser et
inspecté niveau là c'est une
transformation qui coûte plus cher qui
plus spécialisés qui a besoin davantage
de main d'oeuvre donc dans une période
de pénurie de main d'oeuvre mais ça
coûte forcément plus cher de faire ce
type de transformation la même
problématique en épicerie tout le monde
qui je parle à des problèmes de main
d'oeuvre les détaillants à tous les
matins on a un manque de 5 à 15 %
d'employés dans les épiceries c'est un
défi constant
deuxième facteur aggravant la hausse du
prix du grain pour nourrir le poulet
près de la moitié du coût de production
vient du coût de l'alimentation et ça
c'est le prix des grains puis là dessus
les producteurs de volailles ont aucun
contrôle c'est à dire une sécheresse
dans l'ouest canadien doublée d'une
forte demande internationale pour les
céréales et le grain du canada ont forcé
vie prix à la hausse
dans les derniers mois jean philippe
gervais et économiste agricole
surtout pas sous-estimer le rôle de la
chine par exemple dans le marché
elle a commencé à importer beaucoup plus
de meilleurs blues de soyaux et c'est
effectivement un temps où certains pays
producteurs importants le canada la
russie ont eu certains problèmes de
production donc tout
est parfait on est sur la gestion de
l'offre donc les prix doivent rester un
certain niveau peu importe ce qui se
passe troisième facteur la gestion de
l'offre le poulet comme le lait les
oeufs sont régies par un système de
contrôle de la production et du marché
mis en place pour sauvegarder leur
industrie est assurée à 6 de poulet pour
nos besoins avantage on produit 95 % du
poulet qu'on consomme ici cependant
quand le coût du poulet d'ici se mettent
à monter les détaillants ne peuvent
s'approvisionner ailleurs
mais ça se passe vraiment non pas notre
niveau mais au niveau de la ferme au
niveau des abattoirs au niveau des
transformateurs c'est là où est ce que
les impacts de prix se feront sentir et
ensuite son transfert au détail à marc
fortin représente les détaillants nous
on n'a pas le choix nos prix augmentent
donc on suit la même méthode pour mettre
en place les prix on a les mêmes
mécaniques mais simplement le prix
d'entrée est plus élevé ajoutez à tout
ceci le prix de l'essence et le manque
de camionneurs qui vont exploser des
coûts de transport en plus des mesures
déployées pour contrer les effets de la
qu'ovide dans l'industrie alimentaire et
voilà que tout est réuni pour une
augmentation de prix constatés par les
consommateurs mais va-t-on moquer de
poule est ce que vous avez dû remarquer
c'est que des fois il y avait peut-être
un peu moins de produits sur les
tablettes
il marqué certaines coupes au niveau du
poulet rôti ben on va continuer en avoir
c'est certain au niveau des cuisses et
des poitrines on va la voir mais est-ce
qu'on va continuer à aborder des filets
de poulet ou pire encore est ce qu'on va
voir une carence de filet de poulet en
forme d'animaux ben ça va être à voir au
niveau des aliments sur transformer ce
qu'on risque de voir ça va être une once
de coûts plus importants plus de
transformation plus de d'étape avant
d'amener le produit au consommateur
ben évidemment plus tu vends des hausses
de fait le livrer chez vous dans un
plein à 20 dollars certains
restaurateurs biesheim ii récemment des
difficultés à supporter le vent n'ont
pas encore une fois d'un manque de poule
est un manque de découpe de poulet qui
est tributaire de penguin aide aussi les
préférences des consommateurs sont de
plus en plus je dirais exigeant les
consommateurs ou aussi un rôle à jouer
il recherche de plusieurs
caractéristiques de certains produits
que ce soit le type de production la
façon dont leurs aliments et produits
que ça soit une certaine valeur
nutritive qu'il recherche etc et toutes
ses préférences on
oublie que les consommateurs vont devoir
payer
c'est peut-être le temps d'acheter des
poulets entiers et de les apprêter nous
mêmes mais pour ceux qui vivent seules
ou qui ne souhaite pas cuisiner il y as
peut-être de l'espoir avec un retour à
une certaine stabilité
plusieurs raisons pour lesquelles on a
de quoi s'inquiéter première des choses
on est discret où une prière qui est
résiliable pour le démontrer dürer la
part des beats pour pas non plus
conclure que les flat sont vos continuer
à ce rythme là pour une période assez
longue parce que les prix sont assez est
lui déjà présents mais qu'on peut
s'attendre à ce que l'inflation
la variation annuelle commence à
diminuer dans les prochains mois pascal
thériault pour sa part croit qu'on ne
pourra revenir en arrière les
consommateurs canadiens ont été choyés
depuis plusieurs années pour un pays
nordiques on peut se réconforter se
vanter d'avoir aidé panier d'épicerie
les moins chers donc dans certains cas
ce qu'on vit actuellement est une forme
de rattrapage où la main d'oeuvre qui
était moins bien salariés se fait de
plus en plus rares donc si on ressent
embauché embauché deux plus hauts
salaires évidemment que cette hausse de
coûts vost transférés vers le
consommateur donc est ce qu'on va me
manquer de nourriture non est-ce qu'elle
pourrait coûter plus cher ben oui
[Musique]